la parole est à notre collègue agnès
canayer pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'éducation nationale madame la ministre
vous vous êtes féliciter encore ce matin
des bons résultats du bac 2016 88 5 %
des candidats ont été reçus
vous vous en attribuer le mérite un
chiffre qui démontrerait la réussite de
votre politique
quand bien même votre objectif de 80 %
d'une classe d'âge n'est pas atteint
ces statistiques que vous qualifiez de
progrès sans pourtant totalement décalé
par rapport à la 25e place de la france
au classement pisa ces statistiques
valoriser chaque année par le ministère
ne prennent évidemment pas en compte les
20 % de jeunes de 17 ans incapable de
déchiffrer un programme de cinéma
pendant les journées de défense et
citoyenneté
elles ne prennent évidemment pas en
compte les 120000 décrocheurs annuel
comment expliquez vous madame la
ministre la contradiction entre ce que
vous appelez les bons résultats du bac
et le recul de la france dans les
classements internationaux d'évaluation
des connaissances des élèves
ce recul de la france en matière
d'apprentissage n'est-il pas la
principale raison de la panne
généralisée de l'ascenseur social
merci pour vous répondre à paroles et
madame la ministre de l'éducation
nationale de l'enseignement supérieur
najat vallaud belkacem
madame la ministre merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice
canayer alors je pense que d'abord il ya
un effort de pédagogie à faire lorsque
un classement pisa est publié il porte
sur le niveau scolaire des enfants de 15
ans donc qui ont suivi une scolarité
durant les années précédentes
par définition si la france se retrouve
à la 25e place
aujourd'hui des pays de l' ocde c'est
malheureusement le triste résultat de
votre politique d'austérité et éducative
pendant dix ans pardon pardon mais c'est
la triste réalité
revenons en maintenant à votre question
plus générale
même la sénatrice j'ai envie de lui dire
en fait que les fondamentaux d'une
politique éducative sont assez simples
je ne vais pas y aller par quatre
chemins ses fondamentaux c'est qu'il
faut des professeurs dans les salles de
classe alors nous en avons créé 60
milles sur ce quinquennat
là où vous en avez détruit 80 milles ses
fondamentaux
c'est qu'ils font qu'il faut de bons
professeurs qui est de l'autorité sur
leurs élèves
alors nous avons rétabli une formation
initiale des enseignants et nous les
avons revalorisé dans leur rémunération
ces fondamentaux c'est qu'il faut des
professeurs sur tous les terrains et en
particulier là où il avait été
particulièrement absent ces dernières
années c'est à dire dans les territoires
ruraux et dans les quartiers populaires
alors nous les avons recréé madame la
sénatrice en conclusion en conclusion
parce que c'est un mot que sur cette
partie de l'hémicycle on aime bien
utiliser la droite considère que le
mérite finalement c'est d'être né au bon
endroit pour la gauche pour nous pour ce
gouvernement
le mérite c'est d'apprendre c'est de
travailler c'est de réussir quel que
soit son milieu
kial d'origine et nous nous en donnons
les moyens s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît même
cabaye et madame la ministre
c'est l'école de la république fondée
sur le mérite et sur le travail qui a
été le facteur principal du
renouvellement des élites votre
politique votre réponse prouve que votre
politique est avant tout basée sur la
quantité la quantité des enseignants
notamment et non pas sur la qualité des
apprentissages
ce n'est pas en rendant le bac est
accessible à tous par une réduction des
épreuves en offrant le bac au plus grand
nombre que leur garantira la réussite de
leurs études supérieures
le mérite l'évaluation la notation ne
doivent pas être suspect il a il y a
urgence à redonner un sens à la notion
d'éducation nationale merci